-Obviously one of the craziest
things that's happening
right now would think
an impeachment of a Presiden
would be the standout lead story
in the news.
Right now, it is not.
I guess we shouldn't be
surprised that anything
in the present will fade ver
quickly in the past
based on the future.
I mean, that seems to be
how this is happening,
is nothing holds for very long
Are you shocked at how quickly
impeachment has faded
and can we expect it
to come back
into the forefront of the news
-We're still
in the middle of it.
I mean, the most shocking news
I have heard all year in 202
so far is that impeachment was
only 20 days ago.
-Yeah.
-Really?
That wasn't 20 months ago?
It feels like it has been so -
I mean, they're still in the
middle of impeaching him.
The House impeached him.
He's yet to have a Senate trial.
I mean, there's been progres
toward that today,
but we still don't know
when that's gonna happen.
And in the less than three weeks
since he was impeached,
all this additional evidence
has come out
about the core allegations a
the heart of the impeachment
His National Security Advisor,
like his 35th national
security advisor,
John Bolton, has also said
that he will testify
if he's subpoenaed.
That's is a really big dea
given what we know
about Bolton's involvement
in this thing.
So that's still live,
still evolving,
and still animating
the President
if you go by his Twitter feed,
which I don't recommend you do
So it's all still -- And,
by the way, Iowa is in a month
-Yeah.
-We've got the next Democratic
debate happening within a week
except they might cancel i
if it conflicts with
the Senate trial
for the impeachment.
The fight to replace Donal
Trump in the White House -
I mean, this
Democratic nominating proces
is the most consequential, mos
interesting Democratic primary
of my lifetime.
It's like story number 16,
you know,
in any given newspaper
or on any given TV show.
So there's a lot
going on at once.
There is a lot to absorb.
-There's a lot going on
in the minute,
and obviously, you, like us,
you're creating
a show day to day,
but you also found time
to write a book,
a very well-researched boat --
uh, book,
which is about Russia
and about Ukraine
and about natural resources,
and, yet, the timing
of this book,
it was as if you wrote it
on the day
because to write, obviousl
a couple years ago, to decide,
"I'm gonna write
about Russia and Ukraine,"
you never could
have never predicted
that right as your book
comes out,
Russia and Ukraine
are in the news
in a way that really ties
into this book.
-It was really weird.
I set out to write a book
that I was really sure
nobody unrelated to me
would read.
[ Laughter ]
I've been totally obsessed wit
the Russia story
from the beginning.
I make no qualms about it.
I'm still obsessed with it
And I felt like the fact tha
Russia doesn't have an economy
that their whole economy
is based on oil and gas,
and oil and gas tends to b
a very corrupting thing,
I felt like that was
just a piece of the puzzle
that I was interested in,
that I wanted to do
more research on that mayb
my family members
I could guilt them into readin
a small book about it.
And so I wrote this thing,
and then a week before
the publication date,
when I have just received
my first hardcover copy
of the book --
oh, I wrote it,
it's actually been published -
as I get my first copy
of the book,
Nancy Pelosi announces
they are launching
impeachment proceedings
against the President
for a corruption scandal
involving the President
and Ukraine and natural gas.
And I was like,
"I should be investigated.
[ Laughter ]
Clearly I wagged the dog.
It ended up being so weirdly
on the nose that I am unnerved
-It's a wonderful book.
You mentioned you thought mayb
only your family would read it
Your parents do watch your show,
yes?
-Yes, they do.
-My parents watch my show
every night.
Do you get notes?
-Yeah. Do you think about it
when you're doing the show
Like, when you're doing
something, do you think,
"I wonder what my mom's
gonna say about this"?
-It's more that I do something
and I will think,
"I'm gonna hear about that
from my dad." Yeah.
I know what my mom thinks.
She thinks that was the best
show until the next one.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
My dad is like a little -- Yeah,
like, and he'll be like,
"Did you notice?"
And I'm like, "I did notic
and I won't do it again!"
-Is he disapproving or is he
trying to be constructive?
-Oh, very constructive
and incredibly essential
to every piece of success
I've had in my life.
He's the one who kind of round
off the edges,
whereas my mom is just like,
"You be quiet. He's perfec
and he always has been."
-Oh, God!
-What about you?
How do you get it?
-My mom notices -- Okay.
So, I wear the same thing
every day on TV.
Like, I've been
wearing the same uniform.
-What?
-I know. You can do this.
It turns out people don't care
unless they're your mother
So I have three jackets
and three shirts,
and I just rotate them.
That's all.
That's the secret
of my visual success.
But my mom can tell -- There's
one that has a stray thread,
or she gets very upset
if I wear the velvet jacke
in a month
where you could buy oysters.
-Oh, interesting.
-She's got seasonal concerns
about what I look like
and stuff.
So I worry about that.
Also if I get anywhere --
I never swear on TV,
but if I get anywhere
near a swear word,
it's like the antennae go up
the whole family responds,
I have to answer to everybody.
-Alright. That's good.
But it is nice to
find out that they're --
You know, 'cause then every no
and then I would recommend
just dropping an F-bomb to mak
sure they're still watching.
-Exactly!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Mom! You still there?
Exactly.
-Hey, thanks
for making the time.
Have a great show tonight.
Always good to see you.
Rachel Maddow, everybody.